in the last video we set up this
differential equation that described an
LC circuit and now we're gonna go about
solving this this second-order circuit
the technique that works here is the
same that worked with first-order
ordinary differential equations we're
looking for a function of AI that makes
this whole equation true and we're going
to do that by guessing it and I put it
back into the equations and see if it
works
if it works we win if it doesn't work we
have to think of something else and we
keep doing that until we solve it so
knowing what I know about derivatives
and knowing and looking at this equation
can I guess at a plausible solution so
what we have here is two things we have
two terms that have to add up to zero
for all time and so that means that
whatever function I pick for I and
there's some scaling factors here I mean
let me write this this equation like
this
so what I have here is a scaling factor
times I has to somehow fully subtract
from the second derivative of I so these
two these two terms have to somehow look
alike for all time there's one function
I know where its derivatives sort of
look like what we started with and
that's the exponential function so I'm
actually going to make a guess I'm going
to guess that I of T is something of the
form some constant times the exponential
of time with some other scale factor
now K is an adjustable parameter and
that's an amplitude so it tells us how
big the signal is and what's s s is up
in the exponent
along with T and we know that by the
time we take an exponent of anything
that whatever is up here has to have no
units so that means that s t s times T
has no units and that means that s has
units of 1 over time so s is a frequency
of some sort and in particular is going
to be a Radian frequency it's going to
be in radians per second so s is going
to be called the natural frequency so
let's go let's keep working on this
we're going to try to we're going to
plug I back into our equation and see if
it works
so we can plug eyes straight into here
and we need the second derivative of I
so let's let's first take the first
derivative D DT of I equals D DT of K e
to the st and we can take that
derivative and that equals K times s
times e to the st so it's also an
exponential and now we need the second
derivative so we want to take the
derivative of this guy so second
derivative of i with respect to time
equals the derivative of the first
derivative of s k e to the st and that
equals another s comes down so it's s
squared K e to the St good now we have
we have our second derivative we can
plug in in here so let's do that
so the equation becomes s squared K e to
the St plus 1 over LC times K e to the S
T equals 0 let's do a little factoring
there's a common term here there's a
common term ke to the s T and K to the e
to the S T so let me factor that out ke
to the s T times what's left as squared
plus 1 over LC equals 0
okay we have how many adjustable
parameters here we have K s those are
the two L and C are constants that are
values of our circuit so we need to find
some values of K and s that make this
equation zero okay
I can make K equal to zero and that
would mean that zero equals zero so our
amplitude would be zero so if we put
nothing in the circuit we get nothing
out okay that's totally boring so that's
not so interesting of a solution now
does eetu the esti ever become zero e to
something does it ever become zero it
never does if I let T go to plus
infinity and s is negative then e to the
St would become zero but plus infinity
time from now is is pretty far in the
future and I don't want to wait that
long so the interesting solution becomes
can we make s squared plus 1 over LC
equal to zero this equation is referred
to as the characteristic equation
so let's see what happens when we try to
solve this well the first step of this
is I'm going to get s squared equals
minus 1 over LC or s equals square root
of minus 1 over LC oh look what happens
here we're taking the square root of a
negative number so what's going to
happen here we're gonna get an imaginary
number for our answer I can write this
as square root of -1 times square root
of 1 over LC and that gives me 2 two
answers and I'm going to call the first
answer s 1 and that's going to be equal
to J which is the imaginary number
that's the square root of -1 for
electrical engineers times what times 1
a square root of 1 over LC and the other
s 2 is the negative of that minus J so
these are two possible solutions to our
differential equation now I'm going to
make a little I'm going to give a
nickname to this expression here because
I don't want to write it so much I'm
going to call this Omega naught so this
is this is a lowercase Omega
Greek letter this is this is the capital
Omega that we use for ohms but little
Omega is often used as this variable
here so I can say that s equals s 1
equals plus J Omega naught and s 2
equals minus J Omega naught so we're
going to use this notation for a little
bit but just remember I made that simple
substitution we have two different
routes that can cause our differential
equation to go to zero so
we combine these into a solution for I
we're gonna say I equals we're going to
use a combination of these two we don't
know which which one it is it could be
both so there they could be superimposed
on each other and this is what
superposition is for so we're going to
now have we need to have K one will have
two constants e to the S one T plus K 2
e to the S 2 T and I can also write this
as let's fill in some of the some of the
numbers here k 1 e to the plus J Omega
naught T plus K 2 e to the minus J Omega
naught T so that's my proposed solution
and what we need to do now we found s we
found two values of s now we have these
two constants we got to work those out
so in the next video we'll use the
initial conditions to figure out what k1
and k2 are